[موسيقى]
اعصار في ليبيا زلزال في المغرب هزات في
العراق حرائق وجفاف في تونس والجزائر ازمه
مياه في مصر وليبيا والعراق والسودان تاكل
سواحل وسيول في دول الخليج لا يبدو العالم
العربي بمن عما يعيش كوكب الارض مع ارتفاع
غير مسبوق لدرجات الحراره في غير موسمها
وظواهر طبيعيه تبدو غير طبيعيه واثارت
الكثير من الجدل واللغط في نظره متانيه
بعد اسابيع من كارثتي المغرب وليبيا
ارتينا ان نستضيف عالما عربيا بارزا في
علوم الارض لنقطع الشك باليقين ونناقش هذه
الظواهر بكل مسؤوليه وبطريقه علميه بعيدا
عن ما شط ح به خيال البعض من تفسيرات
تجانب المنطق في بعض الاحيان هي محاوله
لفهم ما جرى لماذا نعد ضحايانا بالالاف
بعيد كل كارثه وتمحى مدن وقرا من على
البسيطه بينما دول كاليابان مثلا التي
يضربها اكثر من 2000 زلزال في العام لا
تكاد تسجل خسائر تذكر لا في الارواح ولا
حتى في البنيه التحتيه ضيفنا حذر منذ
سنوات في بحث علمي من ان منطقه شمال
افريقيا ستكون عرضه لكوارث الساحليه وفي
اعقاب ما حدث في ليبيا قال ان درنا ليست
الاسوا لكنها مجرد انذار بما هو اسوا
نحاول ان نفهم معه لماذا وما الذي ينتظر
المنطقه العربيه من شمال افريقيا الى
الشرق الاوسط يدعم كلامه بصور وخرائط
ودراسات وتنبؤات علميه لما هو اتن ويبقى
طبعا العلم عند الله كيف للارض ان تخرج
اثقالها مع مشروعيه سؤال الانسان ماالها
لكن قبل ان نخوض في السؤال سنتابع قصه
الليله العرب وحزام الكوارث نعود بكم من
خلالها الى تاريخ المنطقه العربيه مع
الكوارث الطبيعيه نتوقف مع خبراء للتعرف
على احزمه الزلازل التي تطوق دولنا
العربيه نرصد عن كثب تجربتي تشيل واليابان
في مواجهه الزلازل المتكرره هناك يطلعنا
خبراء بارزون في البلدين على كيفيه رصد
الزلازل والتطورات في معايير البناء بما
يضمن امتصاص المباني للهزات الارضيه
نستكمل بقيه القصه مع الدكتور عصام حجي
عالم الفضاء المتخصص في علوم الارض
والمخاطر الطبيعيه نسال الدكتور عصام عن
الدول العربيه الاكثر تعرضا لتهديدات
ومخاطر الكوارث الطبيعيه خصوصا الزلازل
والفيضانات وعن اسباب تزايدها في العقود
الاخيره وعن التجارب المستفاده من زلزالي
المغرب وتركيا وفيضان درنا في الاستعداد
لما هو ات وكذا الاستفاده من التجارب
العالميه وجلب التقنيات اللازمه للتعامل
مع الكوارث الطبيعيه والحد من خسائرها لكن
لنشاهد القصه اولا وبعدها
الحوار
دال مدمر لم تشهد المنطقه مثيلا له
منذ ويبدو ان حاله من الخوف سيطرت على
الكثيرين في عموم الشرق الاوسط في السادس
من فبراير
2023 وبعد الزلزال المدمرين جنوب شرق
تركيا والذين بلغت شدته 778 و77 وصف درجه
والتي شعر بها سكان المنطقه العربيه
الواقعه شرق المتوسط مرورا بمنطقه البحر
الميت وغور الاردن ووصولا الى رفح وشمال
سيناء وانتهاء الى بحر عمان بمحاذاه اليمن
حيث سجلت حلقه من الهزات الارضيه
المتفاوته في قوتها وتوقيت
بات التساؤل الاهم عن جيولوجيا المنطقه
ومدى استعدادها للتصدي لزلازل محتمله في
المستقبل الزلزال ما عندوش حدود يعني عابر
للحدود لما وقع الزلزال في تركيا تاثرت
فيه سوريا تاطر كبير الزلازل كل واحد وكان
له شخصيه خاصه وهذا يمكن ان نفهمه كل واحد
له بيئته من الصخور المختلفه الضغوط
المختلفه اللي موجوده فيها الصدع المختلف
اللي موجود فيه وانواع صفائح المختلفه
برضه تختلف فيها شده او قوه الزلازل يمكن
ان تنتج عنها مثلا مناطق التصادم كتركيا
زلازل عظمى اما مناطق الانفتاح كالبحر
الاحمر زلازل متواضعه
وقليله ضحايا الهزه الارضيه التي روعت مصر
اليوم ليتجاوز نحو 300 قتيل شهدت المنطقه
العربيه تاريخيا عددا من الزلازل لطبيعتها
الجيولوجيه ولموقعها على حفره الانهدام
والفوالق الصخريه بحسب تقارير هيئه المسح
الجيولوجيه
الامريكيه المنظومه الصدعيه وحركه الصفائح
في المنطقه العربيه
هو
حركه انفراج او اتساع في ارضيه البحر
الاحمر ادت الى احداث
تشوهات تشوهات عاده بتكون مصحوبه بخلل في
اتزان القشره الارضيه مما يؤدي الى
انفصالها عن بعضها البعض فعند ما انها
تنفصل عن بعضها البعض بتحرر طاقه هذه
الطاقه بتنتقل الى سطح الارض على شكل
الامواج مسببه نشاط
زلزالي يطلق وصف الصفائح التكتونيه على
الواح القشره الارضيه التي تكونت عبر
ملايين السنين والتي يترجم تحركها من خلال
التصادم او التباعد الى زلازل وهزات
ارضيه وتقع الدول العربيه في نطاق ثلاث
صفائح العربيه والافريقيه
والاوراك حدود صفائح يعني قريبه من اطراف
بعض الدول العربيه وهنالك ايضا بعض الحدود
تخترق يعني بعض الدول العربيه ولكنها كلها
بالمجمل جميعها يعني يمكن ان تصنف ضمن
نسبيا بانها ضمن النشاط الزلزالي المعتدل
عمليا طبعا كل منطقه تقارب حدود صفائح
هنالك احتماليات ان يكون بها
اخطر تعرف احزمه الزلازل بانها المناطق
المعرضه لنشاط زلزالي بشكل متكرر ومكثف
وتقع الدول العربيه في نطاق ثلاث احزمه
رئيسيه او بالقرب منها وهي حزام شرق
افريقيا
[موسيقى]
وصدع البحر
الميت والحزام الالبي شمالا انشط هذه
الاحزمه ح حزام صدع البحر الميت هذا يعني
ان الدول التي تقع على امتداد صدع البحر
الميت هي من اكثر الدول اللي هي نشطه
زلزاليه ابتداء من سوريا شمالا لبنان
فلسطين عننا الاردن العالم العربي حدود ما
يمكن ان يحصل به اقل ما مما حصل في تركيا
2023 في غاز عنتاب مثلا او في انطاكيا او
حتى في المناطق السوريه التي تاثرت بذلك
اقل بدرجات كبيره لكن قد يكون مؤثرا اذا
كان هذه الزلازل قريبه من بعض المواقع
الماهوله بالسكان يشير اخر تقارير البنك
الدولي عن الكوارث الطبيعيه في المنطقه
العربيه الى تضاعفها ثلاث مرات في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا وحلول الزلازل
مباشره بعد الفيضانات من حيث الخسائر ومن
هنا يبرز التساؤل الاهم هل الدول العربيه
مؤهله لمواجهه الكوارث
الطبيعيه تم اعداد كود للدول العربيه عن
طريق جامعه الدول العربيه في عام 2015 وقد
كنت احد اعضاء هذه اللجنه الا انه في
المنطقه العربيه التطوير
بطيء يمثل كود الزلازل مجموعه قوانين
البناء الهندسيه المصممه لحمايه المنشات
والافراد من مخاطر الزلازل ويعد المرجع
القانوني لمعايير البناء للوصول الى اقصى
درجات المتانه واستقرار المباني المدن
العربيه ل في المناطق الزلزاليه هذه هذا
على خاطر كبير البناات اللي بنت
في
1700 بنت بلا بلا قانون
وهي هشه جدا والخطر تاعها اليوم اللي
موجود في هذه المدن الخطر كبير
جدا تشكل المدن ذات الكثافه السكانيه
العاليه والمباني القديمه تحديا في مواجهه
خطر الزلازل خاصه مع تعرض خمس سكان
المنطقه العربيه لمخاطر الزلازل مستقبلا
حيث يشكل سقوط المباني السبب الاساسي
للوفيات زياده عدد السكان يعني زياده
منشات وهه المشات عندها فرصه اكثر من هبدا
نهار 40% من المباني اذا حصل زلزال بقوه
سته ونصف درجات على مقياس رختر يعني زلزال
قوي سوف تنهار جزئي لكلي
40% التوزع السكاني هو احد اهم العناصر
المهمه في مساله التعرض والانكشاف فكلما
ازداد الضغط السكاني وال المناطق الماهوله
سكانيا فهي معرضه لخطر اكبر وبالتالي
اهتمام الخطط لاداره الكوارث ومنها خطط
اداره كوارث الزلازل مهمه ياخذ فيها
الخطوره الزلزاليه الطبيعيه
والاكسبوكس
[موسيقى]
الزلزاليه المنتشره في العالم مصدرا هاما
للمعلومات والبيانات الخاصه بقراءات
الزلازل ورسم الخريطه الزلزاليه ودراسات
مخاطر
المستقبل شبكه عربيه لرس الزلازل مش
موجوده المعلومات اللي تجي سواء على مستوى
الول عربيه او دول تقريب تقريب في العالم
تؤخذ من من المراكز العالميه كما
ستراسبورغ وك المراكز الموجوده على مستوى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بعض الدول
اللي عندها بعض بعض المحطات صغيره يعني مش
العدد تاعها مش
كبير تعد البيانات عاملا اساسيا للاستعداد
للمخاطر الزلزاليه حيث ان تشيلي على الرغم
من موقعها في حلقه النار في منطقه
جيولوجيه ضمت
81% من زلازل العالم الكبرى بحسب هيئه
المسح الجيولوجيه الامريكيه الا انها
استطاعت ان تكون نموذجا ناجحا في مقاومه
الزلازل ان احد الجوانب الرئيسيه
للاستعداد للزلازل يتعلق بكيفيه تعامل
الناس مع هذه الانواع من الكوارث الطبيعيه
بجانب الاجراءات الحكوميه حيث تقوم الدوله
بالتدابير اللازمه لفهم افضل لمايه هذه
الكوارث من ناحيه اخرى الهندسه الانشائيه
والهندسه المقاومه للزلازل تشهد تطورا
مهما من خلال المعلومات التي جمعناها من
تجاربنا
السابقه عملت تشيل على قوانين بناء صارمه
تشرف عليها وزاره الاسكان بشكل مباشر
وتطور كوتها بشكل
مستمر لدينا المركز الوطني لرصد الزلازل
وهو الهيئه المسؤوله عن مراقبه الاجهزه
واداره المعلومات التي نسجلها خلال
الاحداث الزلزاليه هذه الهيئه مهمه للغايه
لانها تسمح بتوليد المعلومات التي يتم
استخدامها لاحقا لتحديث الكودات الخاصه
بانظمه البناء لدينا من وجهه نظر التصميم
الانشائ
والزلزال
حيث اعتمدت بناء قوائم سميكه وعوارض ضعيفه
لتكون الابنيه مرنه مع حركه الزلازل دون
ان
تنهار تعتمد التجربه التشيليه بشكل اساسي
على المعلومات المحدثه وتثقيف الناس
بكيفيه التعامل مع الاحداث
الزلزاليه الزلزال العنيف ضرب اليابان قار
درجات على
مقس
في حلقه النار ذاتها تقع اليابان والتي
تتعرضوا لاكثر من 2000 زلزال سنويا طبقا
لوكاله الارصاد الجويه اليابانيه لكنها
تعد واحده من انجح الدول في مقاومه
الزلازل بعد سلسله من الكوارث على مدار
تاريخها تم وضع قانون معايير البناء
الياباني في اعقاب زلزال كانتو عام
حيث يحمي القانون حياه الناس من خلال عدم
انهيار المباني حتى لو تضررت في زلزال
[موسيقى]
كبير ان طريقه التصميم الحاليه هي نفس
طريقه تصميم السياره بمعنى اخر عندما
تصطدم السياره ينهار غطاء المحرك بامان
ويمتص طاقه الاصطدام كذلك تم تصميم
المباني لتكون امنه وتمتص طاقه الزلازل
عند تلف الاجزاء تامينيه بالاضافه لذلك
يوجد في اليابان العديد من اجهزه
الاستشعار الارضي في جميع انحاء اليابان
حيث بمجرد حدوث الزلزال تبدا المستشعرات
في الشعور بهزه الزلزال بدءا من المكان
الذي حدث فيه الزلزال مما يسهل البداء
بعمليات الاخلاء من الممكن ايضا اغلاق
المرافق المهمه والالات المهمه قبل ان
يبدا الزلزال في
الاهتزاز طور كود البناء الخاص بها الى
ثلاث مستويات مختلفه المستوى الاول والذي
يعتمد على دعامات فولاذيه او خرسانيه
لتقويه هيكل المباني وتمنعه من الانهيار
المستوى الثاني ويعتمد على مخمدات تمتص
40% من طاقه الزلازل وتوفر المرونه للمبنى
المستوى الاكثر تقدما وهو عزل هيكل المبنى
عن الارض من خلال وحد
ميكانيكيه تتحرك بشكل مستقل مع حركه الارض
اثناء الزلزال وتمثل المباني المطابقه
لمعايير البناء في اليابان
87% بحسب دراسه لجامعه طوكيو
تختلف طبيعه الارض اختلافا كبيرا اعتمادا
على مكان بناء المبنى في البدايه نجري
مسحا ونعتمد طريقه تشييد المباني المناسبه
لكل موقع
بناء
[موسيقى]
انا الان في اسفل المبن حيث تم فصل المبنى
العلوي عن الارض بشكل يبدو انه عائم يتم
وضع الواح المطاط والحديد بالتناوب في هذا
المجسم مما يجعلها ماده مرنه جدا هذا
الجهاز يطيل عمر البناء ويمنع طاقه
الزلزال من التاثير على المبنى مع جهاز
العزل الزلزالي هذا سيكون البناء غير
متضرر
تقريبا تستخدم تقنيات العزل
والتخمر ونسعى لتوسيع استخدامها في
المستقبل امل ان نتمكن من المساهمه في نشر
التدابير المضاده للزلازل
يتم اجراء التبادلات الفنيه لنشر مثل هذه
التقنيات مثل مقاومه الزلزال والعزل
الزلزالي ونحن في الرابطه اليابانيه للعزل
الزلزالي قمنا ايضا بنشر هذه التقنيات في
شكل ورش عمل في العديد من
الدول تبادل بعض بعض المعطيات بعض التجارب
بين الدول الاخرى اللي هي متقدمه كاليابان
مثلا الاستفاده من هذ اولا جلب التقنيات
اللي موجوده عندهم حتى نطبقها في الدول
العربيه ومن التقنيات الاساسيه على
الزلازل هي القواعد العازله للزلازل
بعض البلدان موجود فيها اللي هو الكود
التصميم الزلزالي لكن غير ملزم يعني هذه
مثلا من تج اليابان اهم شيء انهم عندهم
قانون لكن القانون صارم لا يجوز لاي مواطن
انه يصمم بيته ما يكون في تصميم زلزالي
شكل زلزال تركيا في
2023 ناقوس خطر للعديد من الدول العربيه
حيث شددت وزاره الشؤون البلديه والاسكان
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه على ضروره
تطبيق اشتراطات التصميم الزلزالي في
محافظات المملكه كما قررت وزاره الاس كان
في مصر تحديث كود البناء لتفادي الخسائر
حال وقوع زلزال في سلسله من الاجراءات
الحكوميه لتعزيز استعدادات مواجهه الزلازل
في المنطقه العربيه على الدول العربيه
الاعتناء بالاحياء السكنيه القديمه الهشا
اعاده دراستها
وابحث فيها لمعرفه ماذا مقاومتها ل حين
يقع
زلزال هنالك منشات اخرى تكتظ فوق بعضها
وبالتالي تحتاج الى عمليه تقيييم ويتم ذلك
عن طريق التحليل الهندسي الخطي الذي يحكم
على اماكن وجود الفشل والعناصر التي فيها
ضعف والتي تحتاج الى قوه فاذا نجحت هذه
العمليه يتم عمليه الاصلاح عن طريق
التقويه او عن طريق عن طريق التدعيم تساعد
عمليه تدعيم الابنيه على جعلها اقوى واكثر
مرونه من خلال اضافه شبكه خرسانيه مسلحه
تحيط بالاجزاء المراد تقويتها من اعمده
وعوارض او تثبيت دعائم فولاذيه على الاطار
الخرساني لتقويه الهيكل الرئيسي او ادماج
انظمه التخميد مع دعائم الفولاذ ما يوفر
صلابه وقدره اكبر على تبديد الطاقه
الزلزاليه يتم اختيار نوع التقويه ومداها
وتحديد كلفه لما بترفع عمر المبنى بالتقوي
لن تصل الى العمر التصميمي الكامل كانه
عمر جديد سترفع 20 25 سنه اضافيه لهذا
المبنى فاذا زادت هذه الكلفه عن 30% من
انشاء منشا جديد ان تقوم بالازاله وتنشا
منشا بديل عن ه المنشا
القائم تشير الدراسات انه على الرغم من
سعي الدول العربيه لتلبيه مخططات الحد من
الكوارث الا انها واجهت محدوديه في
القدرات والتمويل وتحتاج الى مزيد من
تطوير القدرات التنفيذيه
مستقبلا بدنا ننسق الجهود مع بعضنا البعض
تبادل هذه المعلومات الزلزاليه بين الدول
العربيه وتجاربهم اذا كان فيها يعني هذه
البلاد حصل نشاط زلزالي معين وممكن في هذا
الاطار انشاء ما يسمى
بمرصد عربي للنشاط الزلزالي
كامل يمكن يعمل على الكود العربي العنصر
البشري موجود موجود في كل البلدان العربيه
وقادرين على نعملوا هذا المركز يقدر يعمل
ماما مثلا تكون اتفاقيه مع حمايه المدنيه
العربيه وكل يجيبوا الخبرات تاعهم يحملوا
اتفاقيه يعني كل شي موجود كل شيء سهل ولكن
لابد القرار السياسي يمثل الاستعداد
للزلازل كلمه السر في الحد من مخاطرها
وتشهد التجارب الناجحه في مواجهه الزلازل
ان الزلازل وحدها لا تقتل وان المباني قد
تصمد
[موسيقى]
امامها الاستعداد لمواجهه الزلازل وغيرها
من الكوارث الطبيعيه والعمل على الحد من
تداعياتها بات فرض عين فقد حذرت دراسات
عديده من ان الخطر خطر النشاط الزلزالي في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا قد
يتسارع خلال ال 40 عاما المقبله وتشير
الدراسات الى ان ما يقارب ال 30 مليون من
سكان العالم العربي معرضون لمخاطر زياده
احتمالات حدوث زلازل مدمره في المستقبل
وقد رصد خبراء تطورا مقلقا للنشاط
الزلزالي في المنطقه خلال العقود الاخيره
حيث تعرضت دول عده لزلازل ادت الى خسائر
جسيمه في الارواح والممتلكات احدثها زلزال
المغرب الذي ضرب الشهر الماضي اقليم الحوز
وادى الى مصرع
2960 شخصا واصابه اكثر من 6 الاف اخرين
وقد تعرض المغرب خلال العقود الماضيه
لسلسله في الواقع من الزلازل القويه ضربت
مناطق الحسيمه واكادير كما ضرب زلزال قوي
ولايه بومرداس الجزائريه عام
2003 ووصف بانه الاقوى منذ زلزال ولايه
شلف الذي حدث عام
19 80 اذا اتجهنا الان الى اقصى المشرق
فقد قتل واصيب مئات في زلزال ضرب الاراضي
العراقيه والايرانيه عام
2017 قبل ذلك ضربت الزلازل مصر عام
1992 واليمن عام
1982 وليبيا عام
1963 من جانب اخر حذرت دراسه مشتركه بين
جامعتي كاليفورنيا وميونخ من مخاطر مناخيه
متزايده تهدد عددا من المدن الساحليه
العربيه ولفتت في الواقع الفيضانات التي
اجتاحت شرق ليبيا خصوصا مدينه درنا في
العاشر من الشهر الماضي لفتت الانظار الى
العواقب الوخيمه للفشل في التنبؤ والتعامل
مع الكوارث الطبيعيه حيث ادت الى مقتل
اكثر من
42 شخص في مدينه درنا بينما لا يزال نحو
8500 شخص في عداد المفقودين هذا وقد ادرج
مؤشر المخاطر العالمي الصومال
واليمن ومصر وليبيا في صداره الدول
العربيه المعرضه للمخاطر الطبيعيه والتغير
[موسيقى]
المناخي
ا
[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم مجددا مشاهدينا الكرام وبضيف
الكريم الدكتور عصام حجي عالم الفضاء
المتخصص في علوم الارض والمخاطر الطبيعيه
اهلا بك دكتور عصام نشكرك بدايه على وقتك
الثمين انت قطعت 17 ساعه سفرا وصلت منذ
ساعات فقط للمشاركه في هذه الحلقه
بمعلوماتك القيمه وجئت المشاهد باخر بحوثك
خرائط وبعض الصور وحتى التنبؤات علميا
بخصوص كل هذه الكوارث التي تحدق بمنطقتنا
العربيه فشكرا جزيلا لك سعيد جد ان نكون
موجود هنا شكرا يا اهلا وسهلا كنا نتمنى
ان نلتقي في ظروف افضل لكن انت ترى العالم
من حولنا ومنطقتنا العربيه هي في قلب هذه
الكوارث الطبيعيه هل تغول الانسان تغول
نحن على الطبيعه هو السبب وراء هذه
الكوارث ام ان في الواقع هي ظواهر طبيعيه
موجوده منذ الازل لعل تدفق المعلومات
وجعلها تبدو اكثر اكبر اكثر تكرارا ام
لديك راي في الموضوع بالتاكيد لا النظريه
القائمه او المتداوله على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي ان هذه التغيرات موجوده في
الماضي ان لا شيء اسمه التغير مناخي
والكوكب
يتغير يعني بشكل مستمر الاجابه على هذه
الاسئله بسيطه جدا انه صحيح ان التغيرات
المناخيه كانت تحصل في السابق ولكنها كانت
تحصل على ملايين السنين
الان نرى هذه التغيرات تحصل في اقل من 100
عام اذ لم يكن 50 عام ان لم يكن في في في
ع سنوات اذا نحن نعيش في عالم متغير وهذه
الكوارث الطبيعيه التي نراها ليست نهايه
الكون بل يجب ان تكون نهايه لجهلنا بالكون
الذي نعيش فيه وهي والحديث عنها ليس اشاعه
للذعر وليس لتخويف الناس الذين ماتوا في
دا هرنا وفي المغرب لم يكن يعلموا الليله
التي تسبق هذا اليوم انهم سهلك بهذا الشكل
لم يكن مكتوب على
منازلهم اننا سنهلك نعم هذا قد يسيب اي
انسان اذا ما يحمينا من هذا المصير هو
المعرفه وليست ان نطمئن الناس وليس ان ليس
نكران هذه التغيرات ممتاز المعرفه ذلك ما
حذرت به واسل الكثير من الحبر في د دراسات
لسنوات تحذر من تاكل سواحل في منطقه شمال
افريقيا ودراسات عديده في هذا الموضوع لكن
دراسات لم تلقى نصيبها من الانتشار محليا
قله الوعي قله الاهتمام قله ربما الى
الموضوع اهميه كيف اثر ايضا في ان هذه
الكوارث عندما تاتي الينا تخلف الاف
الضحايا بينما مثل ما ذكرنا تابعنا في
الفيلم تجار في تشيلي واليابان يتعودون
على ذلك اكثر من 2000 زلزال في السنه ولا
ضحايا لا خسائر لا بشريه ولا ماديه اولا
ال مساله الوعي العام هناك غياب تام
بعمليه الاهتمام بفهم الكوكب الذي نعيش
فيه فاعتقد ان ان هو موجود من
من من من عصور وسيبقى معنا بجهلنا به
لعصور في المستقبل وهذا غير صحيح الحياه
على كوكب الارض
ليست شيء مؤكد وجوده في المستقبل اذا
استمرينا بهذا النهج من من الجهل
بالكوكب الذي نعيش فيه فخليني مثلا اوضح م
مثال بسيط في الدراسه الاخيره التي قمنا
بها في مدينه الاسكندريه في مصر ونتيجه
التغير في التخطيط العمراني على مدى
ادراك المجتمعات العمرانيه الجديده
بالمخاطر
البحريه زي العواصف والنوات وغيره اكتشفنا
ان 60% من سكان المناطق الجديده لا يعرفون
اي شيء عن المخاطر الساحليه وهم يعيشون في
اقدم مدينه ساحليه في حوض متوسط طبعا انت
لديك خريطه في هذا الموضوع سناتي ونفصل
علميا لكن اود ان امر سريعا على ما
تداولته وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي كان هناك
لغط اشاعات و عده اشياء نود ان نقف عندها
بطريقه علميه يعني هل هناك بلدان عربيه ان
صح التعبير مكتوب عليها انها منكوبه
وستحدث في هذه الكوارث ام ان الجميع معني
بهذه الكوارث من بلدان شمال افريقيا وصولا
الى الشرق الاوسط الى منطقه الخليج وغيرها
هل هناك من هو في مامن لا يوجد اي احد في
مامن وهو خصوصا بانكار هذه التغيرات
فلناخذ مثال بطيط بسيط ما حصل في دا هرنا
وهو ال العاصفه التي ادت للسيول ومقتل من
5000 الى 8000 شخص تقديريا حصل نفس هذا
الشيء عام
1925 في منطقه الخليج بما يعرف بعامل طبعه
وهو يعني عا حدث اعصار نفس الشيء وفيض نفس
هذا الاعصار وفيضانات وسيول وادى الى
باكثر من 5000 الى 8000 شخص وهو رقم مشابه
وادى الى تدمير 80% من السفن البحريه
الموجوده في منطقه الخليج وادى الى مجاعه
في عام
1925 هذه الاعاصير لم تتوقف عام
1925 هذه الاعاصير ممكن ان تعود الينا في
اي وقت اذا لا احد في من من اي شيء نعود
الان للشائعات والمواضيع التي تم تداولها
بين من تحدث عن وميض وضوء ساطع سبق زلزال
المغرب وقبله حتى زلزال تركيا وبين من
يتحدث عن ربما اي افتعال لكل هذه
المواضيع ونظريه المؤامره وغير سمعنا
الكثير من هذه الاحاديث ما الذي يقوله
العلم ويفصل به في هذه المواضيع بشكل عام
كل هذه الشائعات تدور في فلك واحد ان
المسؤول عن هذه عن هذه الخراب والدمار ليس
جهلنا بهذه الظواهر وانما عوامل اخرى
عوامل الهلاميه التي لا اي اساس لعام
الصحه لا يوجد لا وميض ولا متامر في علينا
ما يتامر علينا هو جهلنا واحساسنا اننا
نعيش في الجزيره معزوله عن التغيرات تع
مشروع هارب الامريكي وغيره كل هذا غير
صحيح كل هذا يهدف ان يشعر المواطن البسيط
ان انني لا احتاج الى تعلم اي شيء انا
ضحيه طبعا طبعا كل هذه الكوارث للاسف تحدث
في العالم اجمع حلقتنا اليوم نخصصها
لمنطقتنا العربيه اليوم في قطر انطلق معرض
اكسبو الدوحه 2023 مثل هذه المبادرات ما
اهميته هل يمكن ان تحدث تاثير هل يمكن ان
تحدث الوعي ما المامول منها بالتاكيد هذه
المبارات مهمه جدا يعني او في بخلال من
خلال هذا المعرض اكسبو 23 وايضا من
خلال المرصد المخاطر الطبيعيه الذي بدانا
في انشاءه من عام 2019 في جامعه حمد به
خليفه ويهدف هذا المرصد ان يكون المرصد
العربي الاول لرصد المخاطر الطبيعيه في
المناطق الجافه بالتعاون مع المراصد
العربيه الاخرى ممتاز وب سمعنا شكوى في
الفيلم من انه لا يوجد مجهود جماعي بهذا
الخصوص هنا لا يوجد مراصد مراصد قليله جدا
وحتى المقترحات
او التي نحصل عليها لتطوير المباني هذه
مبنيه على دراسات في مناطق اخرى يمكن ان
تفيد منطقتنا ويمكن ان لا تفيد منطقتنا
لكن لا تطبق بحدا فها نظرا لخصوص كل منطقه
لا غنى عن وجود مراس عربيه والمرصد الذي
بدانا فيه اتمنى ان يكون النواه للتوسع
والتعاون مع عده مراصد عربيه اخرى على كل
نود ان نستغل باقصى ما يمكن فرصه تواجدك
معنا انت جئت محملا بخرائط ومعلومات علميه
قيمه ان سمحت لنتقدم قليلا نحو الشاشه حتى
نطلع المشاهد الكريم عليها هذه الدراسات
التي كانت لديك نبدا بالدراسه الاولى التي
تحدثت عنها الدكتور عصام الخاصه
بالسواحل العربيه وما حذرت منه من سنوات
بخصوص تاكل هذه السواحل والاثر الذي يمكن
ان تحدثه البدايه كانت من درنا صحيح ماذا
لو تكرمت وشرحت للمشاهد الكريم هذا البحث
المنشور يعني هذا هذا التحذير
الثاني وفي بحث منشور عن مدى خطوره
التغيرات المناخيه على المدن الساحليه في
العالم العربي وما يزيد من هذه المخاطر هي
ثلاث عوامل الاول هي ز زياده التغيرات
الهخه في في منطقه حوض المتوسط الثاني هو
نقص الوعي العام وغياب هي زياده نقص الوعي
العام بهذه المخاطر في المدن الساحليه في
في العالم العربي والثالث وهو زياده عدد
السكان في المناطق المهدده في العالم
العربي كثافه السكانيه ايضا تؤثر ن
الكثافه السكانيه نحن نبني اليوم في
الاماكن التي ستموت فيها الناس بال
امحن 92% وفق تقارير من مساحه العالم
العربي يقطنها ق 92% من السكان العالم
العربي يقطنون 3% فقط من مساحته حتى نتخيل
الكثافه السكانيه بالتاكيد واهميه هذا
البحث مع جامعه ميونخ انه انه التغييرات
العمرانيه
التي التي نقوم بها هي تزيد من اثار هذه
العواصف وتزيد
من المخاطر التي تمر بها المناطق الساحليه
ولماذا لاننا نحاول ان ان نحول الشريط
الساحلي الى منطقه جميله ولا نحوله الى
منطقه امنه وهذا في كل العواصم العربيه كل
مناطق الساحليه تتحول الى الحدائق الخضراء
ولا تتحول الى مناطق تستطيع ان كنا نتابع
الصور الجميله ل درنا وشواطئها التي باتت
للاسف الشديد خرابا بعد ذلك هل هذا ما حدث
في در هل هذا يشرح ما حدث في دمنا سنتحدث
بخرا دا هرنا بالتفصيل الخريطه هذه ربما
تتحدث عن حوض البحر الابيض المتوسط هذا
البحث اين درنا هنا هنا هو هذه هي در هذه
المنطقه هذه هذه النقطه في 2021 نشرنا هذا
البحث مع مجموعه من العلماء في تونس في
معهد علوم البحار واشرنا في هذا البحث انه
هذه المناطق التي باللون احمر مهدده تهديد
عالي باثار العواصف والمناطق المهدده
باللون الاخضر
ورنا هنا هو في في هذه المنطقه مناطق
مهدده باجتياح البحر نتيجه تاكل الشواطئ
وحذرنا لكنه قال يبدو لي اللون الاخضر اقل
خطوره من الاحمر هو اقل و ذلك حدث في ماذا
لو كان لون احمر يعني يعني لو ح حصل لقدر
الله هذا الا صار في طرابلس او في
شمال الدلتا في مصر ستكون نتائج اسوا
بكثير م مما نراه ولكن حذرنا ان ان ان
الحجم هذه الكوارث المناخيه سيتسبب في
هجرات جماعيه من هذه المناطق ممتاز من هذه
المناطق نحن نحضر لحلقه اسمها الهجره
المناخيه بالفعل لاننا تفطن الى هذا
الموضوع ان هناك اضافه للاجئين الذين
يتدفقون لاسباب سياسيه و وهربا من ضنك
العيش باتت هناك هجره مناخيه هل تؤكد لنا
ذلك ما ما ما ربما بعدها الذي سنراه ربما
في السنوات القادمه قد يتصور البعض ان هذا
نوع من التهويل وقد يتصور البعض ان العقل
والرصانة عدم الوعي وعدم وجود مراصد في
منطقتنا اسوا من درنا بكثير وقد يعود
الناس وينظروا لهذه الحلقه انا لا انظر
لاني ارى المستقبل انا ارى ما هو موجود
مخاطر بناء على معلومات علميه مخاط تتزايد
ومراصد تختفي ان لم تكن موجوده اصلا ا
ممتاز انتقلنا الان الى
الاسكندريه اذا هنا اه اه تفضل فهنا منطقه
الاسكندريه منطقه يسكنها في هذه المنطقه
العمرانيه اكثر من 10 مليون شخص منطقه
منخفضه وفيها مجموعه من القنوات المائيه
التي تساعد في تصريف
عمليات مياه العواصف والامطار مثل تهرع
المحموديه التي ردمت اجزاء منها المصبه في
اسكندريه مما مما يؤدي الى عدم القدره على
التعامل مع عاصفه مثل هنات حتى يفهم
المشاهد هنا تجني الانسان على الطب
يد الانسان ويد البشر كيف يمكن ان تزيد
الوضع سوءا بالتاكيد ان مسؤوليتنا هذا
التغير المناخي لم يكن ليكون بهذا الشكل
المدمر ان لم يكن سوء التخطيط العمراني هو
اساس هذه المخاطر سوء التخطيط العمراني
لكن ماذا ايضا ربما عن المشاريع ايضا التي
تقام في في بعض الاماكن المشاريع التي
تقام في كل الشرائط الساحليه في العالم
العربي وبلا استثناء تتعامل بمنتهى
الاستخفاف مع هذه الظواهر التغير المناخي
في اسوا في اسوا الاحوال ولكن في افضل
الاحوال حتى حينما نحاول او المسؤولين عن
هذه المشروعات ان ياخذوا التغير المناخي
في في الاعتبار فلا توجد مراصد ولا توجد
ابحاث ولا تعود في كل مره وتتحدث عن اهميه
هذه المراصد التي تكاد تنعدم في عالمنا
العربيه والتي يمكن ان تساعد بالفعل ان
تقلل من اثار هذه الكوارث ننتقل ربما
للخريطه المقب
دكتور عصام في في الخريطه هنا نحن نهر
القنوات المائيه التي تساعد في تصريف مياه
الكوارث والاعاصير الفيضانات وهو اذا
نظرنا للصور في ضهرنا هنا هناك القناه
المائيه التي كانت تشق المدينه والتي حصل
فيها الفيضان بنشوف القنوات المائيه دي زي
مثلا هنا في حال تهر المحموديه التي هي من
اقدم القنوات المائيه الموجوده في في
منطقه شمال التلتا من هذا المنظر الجميل
في 1940 الى هذا المنظر الاسمنتي في عام
2000 والفنار في 20 عاما فقط كيف تحولت
ماذا فعله الانسان نعم هذ السنوات التي
يفترض ان تصرف هذه المياه بس اخر عقدين
حصل فيهم تدهور في المعرفه المناخيه
والمعرفه العلميه في العالم العربي هو كان
هو هو الجزء الاكبر في الكوارث التي نراها
ا
نود ان ننتقل ربما انت اشرت ايضا الى عده
عواصم على الساحل ربما العربي تحدثت في
دراسه عن المنامه في البحرين عن طنجه في
المغرب وعن الاسكندريه ما الخطر الذي
يتهدد هذه المناطق لو شرحته المشاهد الكري
هي مخاطر مختلفه في
مدينه طنجه هناك مخاطر السيول السيول
الجارفه مثل السيول التي شهدناها في ليبيا
والمجتمعات العمرانيه المبنيه في مناطق
السيول ومع الرغم من عده الدراسات
والتحذيرات الدائمه من السلطات العلميه
الموجوده الى ان المجتمعات العمرانيه
تختار ان تبني في مناطق المجتمعات
العمرانيه يعني هناك يعني دوله يعني لا
يختار الفرد ان ان ربما يبني في منطقه لا
يسمح له فيها بذلك دكتور في جزء في شقين
مسؤوليه في مسؤ فرديه وجماعيه نتفق على
ذلك بس لازم اقول انه ان ان عدم الايمان
المجتمعي باهميه العلم في حياتنا اليوميه
هو ما يجعلنا بهذا يعني انا هدي مثال في
منته البساطه خلال هذا الشهر اغلق مرصد
للمخاطر الطبيعيه في العالم العربي مرصد
اغلق مرصد لاسباب
اخرى هذه هي
المفارقه ومع ذلك لم لم يستاء اي احد او
اي اي شيء لو افترضنا ان ناديين في اي
دوري في العالم العربي تم اغلاق حتى لو
كانوا في دوريات الدرجه الثانيه وفي قاع
الدوري سترى الخبر في كل الجرايد و
وستتفاقم
للخارطة تحدث مره واحده وانها تصيب الغير
واني انا في معزل هي السبب في تدهور
المشهد العمراني في احد
اجمل المدن الساحليه الاسكندريه التي التي
تتحول بهذا التدهور العمراني من المدينه
الصامده التي عاشت 3000 من عام امام
الزلازل والاعاصير
وغيره وفي اخر 20 عام فقط بسبب التظر
العمراني اصبحت تزيد فيها خطوره كل عاصفه
تلو الاخرى الخارطه التي بعدها تتحدث ايضا
عن الكوارث الطبيعيه ونرى في هذه الصوره
بتقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي ما يمكن للاسف ان
تؤول اليه الامور مستقبلا ان لم نتدارك
الوضع هذا المشهد يوري دخول العواصف
الساحليه ودخول مياه البحر في الشريط
الساحلي وما يتحول في المشهد في حاله حدوث
هذا وهذا نراه في الاسكندريه في العواصف
ما يحدث
هو الكارثه هو ان كل البنيه التحتيه
والتحرك في مناطق
ا الدمار التي التي دمرها الاعصار يصبح
شبه مستحيل كان هناك تقرير منشور من ثلاث
ايام يتكلم ان الانتقال من ت هرنا من
الشرق
للغرب ياخذ وقت اربع ساعات في مسافه بضعه
كيلومترات فقط لماذا لان هذا هو المشهد
الذي يحصل في حاله تدمرت البنيه التحتيه
والطرقات تقريبا
بالكامل الان هذا الصوره بتقنيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي لما نحلم جميعا به للاجيال
القادمه لما يمكن ان تكون عليها التطور
العمراني ما الذي يجب ان نفعل ما الحلول
التي يمكن ان نطبقها لنحظى بمدن ساحليه
جميله لكن امنه كما ذكرت الحلول موجوده
ومره
اخرى تغير المناخي ليس نهايه الكون وليس
نهايه البشريه ولكن اداره ظهرنا لهذه
التغيرات هي الخطوره نستطيع ان تطور ونعمل
في مشروع بالتعاون ما بين جامعه ميونخ
وجامعه كاليفورنيا ووكاله ناسا وجامعه حمد
بن خليفه على دراسه تطوير الشريط الساحلي
في المناطق الجافه في منطقه الخليج العربي
ومنطقه شمال افريقيا
افريقيا لكي يكون مقاوم للتغيرات المناخيه
وعمليه المقاومه للتغيرات المناخيه تكون
بالتشجير في بعض الاماكن وتكون بوضع
الاماكن الرمليه والحواجز الرمليه في
اماكن اخرى لكن هناك يجب ان يكون معالجه
للشريط الساح هي معالجه علميه ذكر ضيفنا
في نهايه الفيلم ان كل شيء ممكن لكن يجب
ان يكون هناك قرار سياسي شجاع لت تون عربي
مشترك وجهد جماعي لتدارك الموضوع وهذا
نقطه مهمه لانه مؤتمر التغير
المناخي اللي فات كان في مصر في العالم
العربي مؤتمر التغير المناخي المقبل سيكون
في الامارات في العالم العربي اذا نحن
امام هذه الفرصه لنقف امام
انفسنا وناخذ هذا القرار الهام ان العدو
الحقيقي الذي يجب ان نستعد اليه استعداد
رجل واحد هو هذه هو هذه انا سعيده جدا
بهذه الحلقه دكتور لسبب اننا عندما كنا
نطرح مواضيع المناخ لتقديمها كحلقات في
هذا البرنامج البعض كان يرى الموضوع في
نوع من الترف وهو موضوع نخبوي اليوم بات
هناك وعي اكبر واكبر بهذا الموضوع نتمنى
ان يصاحبه خطوات شجاعه سياسيه من دول
لاتخاذ ما يجب ننتقل الى الخرائط الثلاث
المقبله الخاصه بدرنا درنا انت قلت بانها
بدايه الاس
وليست الاسوا يعني ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث
اكثر حدثنا عن هذه الخريط
بالكيد نهرى هنا معدلات سقوط الامطار في
العاصفه التي اتت على منطقه دا هرنا وهي
هنا ونلاحظ ان العاصفه لم تدخل في العمق
اذا كل المياه
التي تجمعت في السدود تدع تجمعت في السدود
السفليه الاثنين اللي هم اللي اخر قبل
المدينه وهم دولد السدين اللي انهاروا لو
كان لو كان لو كان للعاصفه ان تدخل اكثر
وتحطم
السد الثالث لكانت الماساه اكبر لذلك هي
ليست الاسوا لذلك ما نراه ما نراه هو هو
سوء استعداد منا ولكن ليس هو التغير يمكن
تداركه بالفعل الخريطه الثانيه نبقى دائما
مع موضوع درنا وهذا هنا بوض كميه الاتربه
التي تحركت من الداخل في هذه الصوره
بالقمر الصناعي وبالاحرى التي تحركت من
الداخل الى الشريط الساح هو في الساحل
وبنشوف كل هذه الاتربه والطين اللي تحرك
الى
الشريط هنا في المنطقه الساحليه وكانه تم
ردم هذه الشواطئ هذا ما تحول قوله كانه تم
ردم جزء كبير من المدينه بالكامل ما
خطورته البيئيه الان الخطوره البيئيه الان
ان هو هي اعاده الاعمار كيف ستتم اعاده
الاعمار
بازاله ملايين الامتار
المكعبه من الهين وكيف سيتم البناء فوق
هذه التكوينات الجديده هو امر مش سهل
الخريطه الثالثه وهي الخريطه الاخيره التي
لدينا اليوم وهي متعلقه ايضا
بدرنا
هذه هذه الخريطه باللون الاحمر هي الاتربه
اللي وصلت الى مدينه دهرنا وبنشوف ان
الاتربه دي ليست فقط من احواز المدينه
ولكنها من مناطق
عميقه داخل الشريط الساحلي ونرى هنا
المدينه دهرنا في هذا المثلث
وكميه
الهين الذي يغطي كل المدينه بالكامل للاسف
بعد كل كارثه نحن للاسف في غالبيه الامور
حكومات رد فعل وليست حكومات تخطط لما قبل
هذه الكارثه كيف يمكننا الاستفاده
باعتقادك من هذه الكوارث ان صح التعبير
يعني في قلب كل محنه يجب ان نعرف كيف
نستنبط المنحه التي يبعثها الله بالكيد
العبره ان هذا ما يحصل هو تذكره نتذكر ان
نفس ما نراه في درنا اليوم حصل سنه
1925 في منطقه الخليج والعواصم في منطقه
الخليج ليست مه ليست بعيده عن هذا
السيناريو اذا علينا ان نستعد من الان
بالارصاد
وبنما الرقميه التي تساعدنا في فهم هذه
الضوا الارصاد مراكز الارصاد هذه نقطه
مهمه تشير اليها اشكرك جزيل الشكر دكتور
عصام حجي عالم العالم العربي البارز لوقتك
وحضورك معنا وعلى هذه المعلومات القيمه
التي نتمنى فعلا ان تجد الاذان الصغيه
والاراده السياسيه القويه لتقف وقفه رجل
واحد لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه شكرا جزيلا
شكرا جزيلا ختام حلقتنا هذه من برنامج
القصه بقيه نعود ونلقاكم باذن الله مع
بقيه في قصه جديده الاثنين القادم دمتم في
رعايه الله والسلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم
ه